We're surrounded
by statistical claims,
whether it's a striking graph
going viral on social media,
a politician claiming that life
has gotten 62% better
while they've been in office,
or just something everyday,
like a piece of economic data,
the numbers are everywhere.
So what should we think about them?
Here's one approach -
don't trust any of them.
Mutter something about
lies, damned lies and statistics.
Or joke that 98% of statistics
are made up on the spot.
That seems smart.
After all, nobody likes
to be taken for a fool.
But we can't just reject
all statistics equally.
Statistics can show us
things about the world
that we can't perceive
in any other way.
Instead, we have to exert
a bit of brain power
to figure out what is true
and what is not.
That sounds hard, but perhaps
it's not as hard as you might think.
So here are three easy rules
to make statistics add up -
the three Cs of data wisdom.
First, be calm.
Most statistics come packaged up
with emotional baggage.
They're supposed to make us
angry or joyful or afraid.
Staggering deficits,
shocking rates of crime,
inspiring sums
raised for good causes.
These emotions are why numbers
go viral on social media,
the reason they end up
in the headlines.
There's nothing wrong
with feeling emotions,
but they don't help us think clearly.
So before you share a claim
that has you hot under the collar,
take a moment to notice
your instinctive reaction -
from rage, to denial, to vindication.
Once you've noticed it,
look at the statistic again.
It may seem different now.
Second, get context.
For example, when the
UK Health Secretary said in 2020
that the NHS would save
£100 million over five years
if everyone who was overweight
lost a few pounds.
What should we make of that claim?
What does he mean by overweight,
for example?
And what evidence does he have
to support this claim?
But the most important
piece of context
is simply to understand whether
£100 million is a big number.
It sounds big.
But there are 67 million people
in the UK,
so £100 million is just £1.50 each.
You can figure that out
on your phone.
Now remember that £1.50 each
was spread across five years.
So that's 30 pence
per person, per year.
The Health Secretary then said
that if every overweight person
lost some weight,
the NHS would save the equivalent
of 30 pence per UK resident per year.
Not a lot.
Statistics can be a very
complex subject,
but you can get a long way with
simple questions about context.
What's being measured here?
Is it going up or going down?
Is it big or small?
What's the source of the claim?
You don't need a lot of fancy maths,
just a search engine,
the back of an envelope,
and a curious mind.
Which brings me to the third
important principle - be curious.
When we use a number as
a weapon in an argument,
or a prop for our preconceptions,
we learn nothing.
Instead we should think
about statistics
as a tool
to understand the world,
like a telescope for an astronomer.
Ask yourself what a statistical claim
is really telling you
about the world
and what questions it inspires.
Of course we don't have time to
do all this for every claim we see,
so a final habit is to ask yourself
whether the source
of a statistical claim is respecting
the three Cs.
A good journalist will help you be
calm, will give you context,
and will feed your curiosity.
A viral 'gotcha' circulating
on Twitter or WhatsApp
will often do the opposite.
We shouldn't just accept
statistics unthinkingly,
but neither should we dismiss
them without thinking either.
Three simple habits - be calm,
get context, and be curious -
can help the world add up.